now Ukraine says it shot down several
drones over the capital Kiev no injuries
have been reported but it comes the day
after Russian drone strikes targeted
karkiv in northeastern Ukraine damaging
a college dormitory
let's speak now to Steph Mason who's in
the Ukrainian capital and step there
have been several strikes overnight
across the country what's been targeted
and where
yes absolutely there were drones coming
from the Black Sea that have been
attacking ports south of Odessa again
and authorities are reporting that grain
storage facilities there have been
damaged and a fire broke out the
landscape right at the landscape
immediately condemned the attack he
wrote on his telegram channel that
Russian terrorist as he describes them
once again attacked ports grain and also
Global Food security and we've seen in
the last couple of weeks since this
Grand deal collapse of Russia pulled out
of it we have seen several attacks on
the port facilities in Odessa and also
it's been reported that a grain export
from Ukraine of course a very important
export of grain is down 40 percent in
the month of July and as you said also
kievas under drone attack 10 drones were
intercepted according to authorities and
only some debris have fallen down but
nobody got injured there were no
casualties and of course step you know
as the fighting continues sort of the
Medics are hard at work but they're
finding their job made more difficult
aren't they why
yes exactly
at the front lines is a very intensified
at the moment the Ukraine has been
reporting some advances but what we're
hearing is also lots of casualties and
lots of wounded so we went to khakif we
spoke to some Medics who work on the
front line and they report that there's
really urgent need of medical supplies
but they also say that some donations
are very bad they're the equipment they
are sending is not usable